Hello there!
OpenAI’s CLIP and DALL-E have
been out for centuries now.
What? Centuries? Ms. Coffee Bean, it’s been only 3
weeks now, but I think you all agree with us that
3 weeks in machine learning feel like a century!
Meanwhile Google published the Switch Transformer
of 1 Trillion parameters, Transformers generate
music, Transformers generate 3D Dance motion,
Transformers detect 3D objects....
And the list goes on and on.
So let’s stay cool and avoid being overwhelmed.
In a previous video where we discussed OpenAI’s
Dall-E, we found out that it is great at
generating images from natural language.
And it might look like creativity especially when
combining concepts like "armchair" and "avocado".
To make sure that DALL-E’s generations
are fitting the description well,
OpenAI employed a separate model called
CLIP to rank the image generations
after their similarity to the text.
And if you do not know about DALL-E yet,
check out our video about it linked in
the description below. It's worth it!
In this video, we will talk about this
helper model of DALL-E called CLIP.
But do not be deceived by us calling it a "helper"
model; it is more than impressive also on its own.
Make sure to stay until the end where we will show
what amazing things people did already with CLIP.
CLIP stands for Contrastive Language–Image
Pre-training and yes, the paper has
a different title altogether. Anyway, based on
the paper, we will be answering the questions:
What can CLIP do?
What are the ingredients for its success?
What are the limitations of
CLIP? Because there are some.
And what can we, mortals do with CLIP
and what applications already exist
based on CLIP? Because in comparison to
DALL-E, CLIP was already shared by OpenAI.
CLIP is very good at telling
if an image and a short
piece of text belong together or not.
But why do we want to know if a given text
and image fit well together in the first place?
Well, because this task formulation is general
enough to derivate many other tasks from it:
Like image recognition on ImageNet, for example.
The task there is to classify images. And this is
what neural networks have been been doing so far:
They take all available classes in the dataset
(here the dog races) and up to 1000 other classes
and assign a probability for each class. The
highest scoring class is the classification
prediction of the model, here "king Charles
spaniel". But with CLIP it gets even better:
Because of the way it was trained, CLIP is not
restricted to the classes from the dataset,
but knows virtually all English words, being
able to formulates the ImageNet classes into
prompts containing more language than just
the classes. And here we already see why
CLIP has the potential to be so much
better than it’s competitors: Firstly,
it can also model the notion of “photo” or “image”
or “satellite”, extending it’s capabilities far
over a restricted set of classes, showing
great zero-shot performance on unseen datasets.
Secondly, CLIP is during training never restricted
to reduce an image to a single concept or word,
therefore it never loses or forgets other aspects
of the image that are not captured in the class,
like the grass or wood on the background.
Impressively, but not perfectly, CLIP can
solve tasks and datasets it has not explicitly
seen during training, like optical character
recognition, geo-localization, texture detection
and others like facial emotion recognition,
and action recognition. It is impressive zero-shot
performance for a model trained only to predict a
similarity between a text prompt and an image!
Then what are the ingredients to CLIPs success?
Here we have to say that the
employed ideas are not really novel,
there are a lot of ideas used in the CLIP
paper that where already used in research.
And OpenAI’s merit is definitely that it managed
to put everything together in a fine piece of
engineering, which CLIP is (whisper: and DALL-E!).
Yes, the zero-shot capabilities of CLIP are
impressive, but not unexpected; we have seen it
happen too with GPT-3 trained on huge amounts of
data with high-variance: CLIP has been trained on
400 million images with paired text descriptions.
This is 100 times more data than ImageNet,
and it is very diversified data too,
because as it was all scraped from the internet.
So, the first ingredient for to the success
of CLIP is of course, the data. The more data
the better and the more diversified the data,
the more we can expect the model to be
able to perform afterwards in zero-shot.
Then on this data, CLIP was trained like this:
The authors take a batch of images and a batch
of their corresponding textual descriptions.
The images are encoded, by either a ResNet or
a Transformer and the text is encoded by a
transformer too. Then for each image in the
batch the encoder computes an image vector:
so the first image corresponds to the vector
I_1, the nth image to I_n and the same happens
for the textual description: the first textual
sequence is encoded by one vector T_1, the nth
description by T_n. Then the magic happens:
n square similarities are computed
between all these images and text vectors.
This means that the diagonal
elements should be maximized by CLIP,
as I1 fits with T1, I2 with T2 and so on.
In a contrastive fashion, the off-diagonal
elements should be minimized, since
we assume that is really unlikely
that an image I1 fits with a random
other description other than its own.
And this the second ingredient for the success
of CLIP is the idea of predicting similarities
between images and textual descriptions
and training in a contrastive fashion.
But this idea is not new at all but have been
seeing this idea in Multimodal Transformers
as a pretraining task, like for example in
LXMERT or ViLBERT, VisualBERT and so on.
So this is sadly some piece of related
work that we think the authors did not
acknowledge enough and compare to... well…
The third element that the authors advertise
CLIP with, is it’s computational efficiency:
Especially when these image and text encoders are
transformers, we know that a lot of computations
can run in parallel compared to LSTMS for example.
But do not confound computational efficiency with
data efficiency: especially with transformers
that do not have inductive biases that help during
learning from little data, they need more data to
learn well. So they are not that data-efficient.
So the fourth ingredient to CLIP’s success comes
from the image and text representations
gained during training on the given data:
CLIP now trained to predict high
similarity for fitting image-text pairs
and low similarity for random ones is ready to be
applied on various tasks, like image recognition.
We remember, image recognition only
has one word to describe one image,
CLIP rather likes more words, like a description,
so the authors create a prompt, “a photo
of a” and then they insert all possible objects,
creating as many prompts as there are objects.
Then, they compute zero-shot the
similarity between a say, ImageNet image
and these text prompts that differ only in the
mentioned object. Then the prompt and object with
the highest similarity is chosen as prediction.
And the same CLIP model performs really well,
not only on the classical ImageNet image
recognition challenge, but on many other tasks
with different kinds of images, or styles because
first: it has seen these image styles during
training and secondly it has seen the words to
describe these kind of images and their details.
Ok, so CLIP can do so much, and it is time to
see what the limitations are of CLIP: Here we
must refer to the "Limitations" section of the
CLIP paper, because it is the most entertaining
limitations section we have ever read. We
include the passages we refer to and cite,
so you do not think that the used language is
really ours: no, they really, really formulate
things like we show them here. Sot he authors make
clear that zero-shot CLIP is competitive with the
baseline of a supervised ResNet-50 model, trained
specifically on the training set of that dataset.
And this is impressive, because it means that CLIP
trained on OpenAIs dataset of 400 million images
absolves us a little of training specifically
on tasks and the datasets associated with them.
But here the authors warn us, that there is still
work needed to beat the supervised baselines. But
this work can have limitations if it
is done how the authors did it so far:
they warn us that if we scale the model and
the data like they did so far, we would need
a 1000 times more resources in compute,
which is infeasible with current hardware.
Then, the second limitation they tell us
about, is that: while CLIP is performing
amazingly on some zero-shot tasks, it
is not amazing on all tasks: We cite:
"The performance of CLIP is poor on several
types of fine-graind classification such as
differentiating models of cars, species of flowers
and variants of aircraft." And CLIP has also
trouble with "abstract and systematic tasks such
as counting the number of objects in an image."
CLIP has also trouble with tasks that are unlikely
in the pretraining dataset by saying that CLIP has
troubles generalizing to out-of-distribution
images. And they illustrate with an example of
optical character recognition, where CLIP is
really good at recognizing digitally rendered
text, but has troubles with MNIST, which
is a dataset containing handwritten digits.
And the reason the authors can identify is
that there are a lot of digitally rendered
text images in CLIP's training data, but
not so much handwritten digits and CLIP
kind of fails to generalize from digitally
rendered text to handwritten text.
And kind-of the next limitation they address
is that CLIP is not a caption generation model.
It can only tell you how a given, an existing
image and an existing text fit together,
but it cannot really compose new text.
And, also a very beautiful formulation:
CLIP also, I cite: "CLIP does not address
the poor data efficiency of deep learning.
Instead CLIP compensates by using a
source of supervision that can be scaled
to hundreds of millions of training examples."
So CLIP didn't solve any of the deep learning
problems, but it kind-of chose a
bigger hammer for solving the problem.
Okay, but now that we know what the authors
found out that CLIP cannot do, let’s have a
short look at what people have been able to do
with the CLIP model that was released by OpenAI:
And the first application we want to show you, is
this one by lab member 001 who was able to discern
between grainy, noisy photos and high-quality
photos. He could really nicely formulate in
natural language, because CLIP understands that.
So in a sense CLIP can be used as an image search
engine, as for example Vladimir did, who used CLIP
to retrieve car images, but it gets even better:
He could retrieve even more detailed things,
like "car driving in the woods". So this is
the best thing about CLIP: You can describe
to the model very detailed what you want.
And you can retrieve pictures like this
one, where it is raining cats and dogs,
and also what I really liked is this example
of detecting chemical elements in pictures.
CLIP delivers us similarities or scores,
between an image and a text, so it can be
easily used as a discriminator in a GAN.
Here is a super-nice example of a Montreal
image. Find the links to the tweets I have
shown you so far in the description below.
And also in the description, please find the
link to this Google Colab released by OpenAI
where you get working code that you
can explore in your own appplication!
There are detailed instructions how
to download and initialize the model
and then there is even an example
how to calculate similarities between
images and pieces of text and also how to create
your own ImageNet-like classifier with CLIP!
So you can play with CLIP on Colab yourself,
do not forget to find all the links mentioned
in the description below. Let us know what cool
things you have created with CLIP in the comments
and see you next time!
Okay bye!